je porte gardée de suite la carte je
pensais que c'était une publicité comme
une bouteille à la mer une carte postale
déposé dans la boîte aux lettres de lise
rochette lui a fait faire une rencontre
extraordinaire celle d'alec flex heures
il est mort au jour j à juno beach puis
l'habiter ici quand il est parti à la
guerre et tout de suite il ya plein
d'imagés qui me sont venues et j'ai
trouvé sur internet
quelle époque il vivait ici avec ses
parents avec un frère de 12 ans alors
j'ai pas pu m'empêcher d'imaginer la
grande douleur de cette famille quand
ils ont appris le décès de ce jeune
homme là son appartement ne sera plus
jamais le même
sinon on est heureux ici depuis 35 ans
ça rajoute une couche d'histoire alors
pour l'épauler lui ici ça rajoute
beaucoup il y as 400 cartes postales
personnalisées qui ont été envoyés comme
ça à travers le canada par le centre
juno beach le musée canadien en
normandie
créé par des vétérans il ya 15 ans 400
parmi les 900 trois soldats canadiens
tués le 6 juin et les 4 jours suivants
le débarquement en 1944 par des morts
dans lequel on a des archives on regarde
la drees qui à presse-océan nains faut
aller trouver si cette adresse là
existent encore
s'il ya un code postal ce la maison
lapointe et détruit seulement cinq
personnes se sont manifestées dont la
mort est à l'aise lise rhj est le centre
juno beach va faire d'autres envoient
dans les prochains mois pour rappeler
d'autres soldats canadiens tombés tout
au long de la bataille de normandie
parts de quelque chose qui est
totalement anonyme une tombe
à l'étranger pions on arrive à quelque
chose dans un rapport entre une mère et
son fils les dernières lettres avant
qu'ils partent faire le débarquement en
normandie
le soldat en question il ya son acte de
nécrologie les archives juives de la
ville de montréal ont des pièces sur lui
puis elle en a trouvé d'autres comme une
façon de faire revivre l'histoire
ces événements à la date de 75 ans c'est
comme si c'était hier
et ça me donne envie d'aller sur place
des lits lui ali faire un tour en
normandie
c'est ce que le cheval y déposer des
fleurs sur sa tombe lui rendre hommage
ici anne lise despatie radio canada
montréal